[Music]
on this Thursday night the
record-shattering need for food banks
the ramifications of the rising cost of
living we're hearing parents going
without meals to make sure that kids
have meals and to please for help
Rising cases of children infected with a
respiratory virus I watched her body
completely deteriorate the symptoms of
RSV to watch for and who's most
vulnerable controversial guest at the
Saskatchewan legislature I would have
done that differently the Uproar over
former politician turned convicted
murderer Colin Thatcher's invite and New
Revelations from the red planet what
NASA has detected and discovered on Mars
[Music]
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us we all
know the cost of living is rising
especially the cost of food now there's
a snapshot of how many people are
turning to food banks to feed their
families a new report reveals Food Bank
usage in Canada in March was the highest
it has ever been food banks Canada says
a record number of people turn to food
banks nearly 1.5 million visits in March
the unemployment rate that month was 5.3
percent the lowest it's ever been
suggesting the Working Poor with steady
incomes can't afford to buy food since
2019 Food Bank usage went up 35 percent
it's a surge that hasn't been seen since
the recession in 2008. there are
multiple factors at play inflation
Rising interest rates and energy costs
and there are parts of Canada where food
banks can't keep up with demand Heather
urich's West has our top story tonight
the doors of this University campus food
bank in Newfoundland are shut tight
because the shelves inside are bare the
rising cost of living means there are
just too many in need of help I can't go
shopping I have to stop eating like as
much as I used to because I can't go
shopping anymore I can't keep
overspending my limit here in
Newfoundland the uh
cost of rent is um kind of gotten out of
control we have people living in tents
the cost of food here I would think is
probably the highest in Canada or close
to it the problem is far from
Newfoundlands alone in all provinces and
territories more Canadians are
struggling to make ends meet food banks
are under more pressure than ever before
our hunger count 2022 report is really
what I would call a devastating wake-up
call in March 2022 nearly 1.5 million
people turn to a food bank for support
which is the highest number we've ever
seen in our history in this country well
nationally Food Bank use has risen by 35
percent since 2019 the change was even
sharper in Ontario and Quebec though the
biggest increase by far was seen in
Alberta where demand has shot up by a
staggering 73 percent unfortunately in
Alberta and specifically in Calgary
there are a number of people that are
still employed and needing to access
services like the food bank and that's
because their wages aren't covering the
skyrocketing expenses Calgary's food
bank is coping with the growing demand
for now but it's the future that's
causing concern as Canada confronts a
nationwide poverty problem that appears
to be intensifying quite frankly we're
scared of what this will mean we're
thinking that we're on a brink of a
Health crisis here in Ottawa we have
people who are coming to programs and
passing out because they haven't eaten
in several days it's why food banks
across the country are calling for more
government support changes to National
Poverty policies so that food banks
aren't left to shoulder the country's
ever-increasing burden of hunger alone
Heather urich's West Global News Calgary
there are some encouraging signs the U.S
economy is rebounding faster than
expected after shrinking in the first
half of the year the American growth
domestic product grew by an annualized
rate of 2.6 percent in a period from
July to September exceeding expectations
President Joe Biden says it's further
Evidence the economic recovery in the
U.S is continuing to power forward the
housing market and consumer spending
though are continuing to slow down
at the same time one of the world's
largest oil and gas companies is having
its most profitable year ever shell
posted a third quarter profit of 9.45
billion dollars U.S and is on track to
exceed its most profitable year 2008
when it reported 31 billion dollars in
profit despite those earnings shell paid
zero in the UK's new windfall tax on
energy companies saying that's because
of major Investments it made no profit
there
there's growing concern about a common
respiratory virus surging in many parts
of this country it's called RSV and it
infects the lungs and respiratory tract
young children are especially
susceptible to it it causes cold-like
symptoms but in rare cases it can result
in severe illness and even death Jamie
Maraca explains what's driving the surge
in cases
Jade McConnell should be celebrating her
daughter London's fifth birthday this
week instead the BC mother is warning
parents about the childhood virus that
claimed the then one and a half year
old's life I watched her body completely
deteriorate it started affecting all
other organs in her body
her heart her kidneys like everything
and just it was one thing after another
born at 23 weeks London had already
survived one case of respiratory
syncytial virus or RSV but her lungs
were too damaged to withstand another
preemies and children with asthma are
extremely vulnerable to the virus red
flag symptoms are one if their child
seems to be breathing with some
difficulty so that might look like rapid
breathing or they're using excess
excessive muscles to breathe like their
shoulder muscles or drawing in at the
rib cage or in their bellies those signs
may require an immediate trip to the
hospital where kids are tested for RSV
the latest Canadian data shows positive
cases are increasing with the sharpest
climb in Quebec pediatricians worry it's
adding to a load they are already
struggling to Bear there's no beds you
know in the hospital I work at uh 12 out
of 12 beds are filled with children with
RSV Global News contacted Children's
Hospitals across the country most
explained the case counts are a return
to pre-pandemic levels only they are
surging earlier than usual overwhelming
in the face of a trifecta of RSV covid
and the flu at the Children's Hospital
of eastern Ontario it's meant canceled
surgeries and ER wait times in excess of
15 hours it's like the perfect storm so
you have the combination of both a
larger susceptible cohort of kids in
combination with behavioral stuff so
like back to school and circulation of
all the the mix of viruses at the same
time before London Jade says she had
never heard of RSV her son has since
contracted the virus and recovered now
she wants to make sure other parents are
prepared don't let your child wait it
out at home before it gets worse because
it can get worse really really fast
being proactive she says could save
their life
Jamie moroccer Global News
evidence presented today at the inquiry
into the use of the federal emergencies
act reveals the federal government was
discussing the possibility of invoking
it as early as the first week of the
protests in a February 5th text
conversation RCMP commissioner Brenda
Luckey said the government of Canada is
losing slash lost confidence in the
Ottawa Police Service 10 days later
prime minister Justin Trudeau invoked
the federal emergencies act today OPP
commissioner Thomas Carrick measured his
words when asked if he maintained
confidence in the Ops the lead police
agency
confidence is is a harsh and strong way
of putting it this is a police service
that is in a very uneven envelope
position
um is struggling to move forward with an
operational plan
my job was to support them
support included tow truck services
Carrick testified he did not need
emergency powers to get tow truck
companies on board but said the
emergencies act helped by providing
drivers with indemnification something
they demanded the emergency Powers
allowed police and City officials to
commandeer tow trucks to move those big
rigs and other vehicles if Towing
operators still refused
Saskatchewan's Premier Scott Moe is
responding to criticism about one of the
guests invited to the speech from the
throne at the legislature yesterday
former MLA Colin Thatcher who spent
almost two decades in prison for
murdering his wife was invited by a
current MLA and good friend
I would have done things differently
personally but these are these are guest
lists that I don't bet I don't know if
the speaker vets them I but I most
certainly don't and I won't be I could
stay in here Thatcher who is now 84 was
a millionaire Rancher who served at
Saskatchewan's energy minister in the
early 1980s he and his wife divorced and
waged a bitter highly publicized custody
battle over their three children in
January 1983 in the garage of a Regina
home an assailant bludgeoned her 20
times and then fired a bullet through
her head 15 months later Thatcher was
charged and in 1984 convicted of
first-degree murder he has always
maintained his innocence groups who
support victims of domestic violence
have called Thatcher's attendance at the
throne speech disturbing the opposition
calls it hypocritical for a government
that delivered a throne speech that was
in part focused on getting tough on
crime the MLA who invited Thatcher now
says it was an error in judgment
a potential bid led by four BC First
Nations to host the 2030 Olympic Winter
Games has hit a huge roadblock the BC
government said today it will not
support the bid because it believes the
risks and costs of hosting the games
outweigh the potential benefits and the
priorities should be Health Care Public
Safety and helping people with the cost
of living in July it was estimated the
games would cost between 3.5 and 5.5
billion dollars
protesters in Iran will not give up
coming up resistance to Iran's
repressive regime keeps growing
foreign
there have been other protest movements
in Iran but none like this
this is about so much more than what
women wear it's about the repressive
regime thousands went to a cemetery
yesterday to Mark 40 days since the
death of Masa amini who died after being
arrested for wearing her hijab too
Loosely now women girls and men in Iran
are prepared to do whatever it takes to
try to change their lives Redmond
Shannon reports oh the protests in Iran
are snowballing
this one in memory of a fellow protester
Nika shakarami killed in September more
than 200 people have reportedly died in
the backlash against demonstrations the
UN now calling for an international
investigation
Wednesday saw a wave of marches and
vigils in memory of Masa amini
marking 40 days since her death in
custody she was detained last month by
Iran's morality police for wearing her
hijab incorrectly
this crowd gathered at the cemetery
where the 22 year old is buried
many protesters are chanting death to
the dictator in reference to supreme
leader Ayatollah Khamenei a sign of the
widening anti-government sentiment the
Grievances are very deep-seated so I
don't think that uh you know it's gonna
end anytime soon even if this current
wave of protests is going to be
repressed this german-iranian political
scientist believes the regime is
crucially losing the support of its base
Iran's poor how long you know they're
going to be able to shoot uh you know
the protesters to use lethal means to
confront them
when the social basis may also be
enlargening Iran's government is blaming
foreign forces for fomenting the unrest
sanctioning European ngos and media
Outlets meanwhile the so-called Islamic
state has claimed responsibility for
Wednesday's attack that killed 15
worshipers at a I Shrine there is no
evidence it had any connection to the
protests but Ayatollah Harmony used the
tragedy to call for Unity in Iran it's a
request that many are likely to ignore
Redmond Shannon Global News London
Ukrainian and Russian soldiers are
digging in ahead of what's expected to
be a fierce battle for control of the
city of Curson along the Ukrainian front
line soldiers say they are seeing
Russians bolster their positions with
newly mobilized conscripts digging lines
of trenches croissant is the only major
Ukrainian city that was seized during
the first wave of Russia's invasion in
February over the past couple of weeks
authorities appointed by Moscow have
begun evacuating tens of thousands of
people from the city Iran and Ukraine
were among the topics on the agenda as
the U.S Secretary of State Anthony
blinken made his first official visit to
Canada today Eric Sorensen reports on
the significance of meetings like this
between Neighbors
he is not a world leader but few foreign
visitors wield as much clout on a visit
to Ottawa as Anthony blinken the U.S
Secretary of State is here to work with
and pressure Canada at a time of
multiple International crises this
backdrop for blinken and the Deputy
Prime Minister and foreign affairs
minister the Ukrainian hall now a hub to
help some of the thousands of Ukrainian
refugees that have come to this country
it goes to what makes Canada so special
blinken praised Canada's efforts in
Ukraine but it was behind closed doors
that a new crisis was confronted
the violence and Chaos in Haiti Canada
with long-standing connections to the
troubled nation has sent a team to
assess what is needed to restore
security and provide basic needs
the Haitian government has asked the U.N
for an international Force to help
could Canada lead such a mission neither
blinken nor Jolie would commit to such a
force yet who might be willing to
participate in such a mission as well as
who will lead it and that's an ongoing
conversation that we're both having and
having with uh with others so this is a
work in progress Jolie said the first
priority is to help the Haitian police
restore security and to provide
humanitarian help we definitely need to
support Haiti to make sure that and and
bring the International Community to
support Heavy D facing this important
crisis there's also a limit to what
Canada can offer recently the chief of
Defense staff declared bluntly and
publicly that our armed forces are
stretched thin but I will tell you that
the the military that we have today is
not the military that we need for the
the threats that are appearing in the in
the future as close as blinken came to
criticizing his hosts was on the
question of Canada's military capacity
which falls short of NATO's expectations
spending a certain percentage of our GDP
on defense for countries this is a work
in progress that requires us I believe
all to do more to provide for our common
security as blinken met with prime
minister Trudeau Lee today he's also
preparing for further talks tomorrow to
address something both countries want to
improve cross-border trade Eric Sorensen
Global News
[Music]
restrictions for voters in the state of
Georgia ahead ahead are certain
Americans being blocked from casting
their ballots
[Music]
in 12 days Americans will vote in
midterm elections early voting is
already underway in the state of Georgia
and voters there face tough new
restrictions as a result of former
president Donald Trump's lies about
fraud in the 2020 election as Jackson
prosco reports voting rights groups say
black and urban voters are being
deliberately targeted
hours long lines for early voting are
the clearest sign of the confusion and
concern around new voting rules in
Georgia we try to just earlier go to our
normal place where we dropped off our
absentee ballot but we learned that
Ballot Box is not there this is the
largest election in the state since a
restrictive new voting law came into
effect known as SB 202 it makes it
tougher to request and file an absentee
ballot it even bans volunteers from
handing out food or water to voters
stuck in those long lines voting didn't
happen doesn't have to be this way it
doesn't have to be this complicated it
doesn't have to be this controversial SB
202 also allows anyone to challenge the
validity of an unlimited number of voter
registrations election officials have
been swamped by an estimated 65 000
challenges to date it takes up a lot of
a lot of there and start doing whole
controlling processes the new
restrictions were passed despite the
fact that multiple recounts Audits and
court cases found no evidence of
widespread voter fraud in the 2020
election voting here was already
considered safe and secure now it's also
more difficult proponents of SB 202 say
the law prevents hypothetical
counterfeit ballots from being cast they
claim the security of the 2022 midterm
elections is still in Jeopardy even with
the new measures I know that people are
saying it's not voter suppression it is
voter suppression voting rights activist
Helen Butler argues the changes
disproportionately hurt black and
minority voters in Atlanta where
Democrats dominate there are now just
eight ballot boxes in Fulton County down
from 33. they used to be open around the
clock now they're only open during
Limited hours Ain't No Mountain High
Enough that can stop us from voting so
whatever the barriers you put in place
yeah we're going to figure a way to make
it happen it's no understatement that
every vote here counts in 2020 President
Joe Biden won Georgia by just 11 000
votes the current Senate race between
Herschel Walker and Rafael Warnock is a
dead heat people supposed to come out
early they can pretty much you know we
can you know we can turn on to match
numbers that's why SB 202 is the wild
card in this election both Democrats and
Republicans feel like they have no
choice but to vote early and in person
to make sure they can vote at all
Jackson prosco Global News Atlanta
insights into Mars next NASA's explosive
new discoveries about the red planet's
surface
[Music]
Mars has long been the object of
Fascination in the night sky fodder for
Hollywood and for those hoping to one
day have humans live there well today
NASA revealed new information from a
pair of its Mars missions that hold some
valuable Clues and warnings for any
potential human settlement Ross Lord
explains
it's a sound we've never heard before
an earthquake on Mars known to NASA
scientists as a Mars Quake the rumbling
aftermath of a space rock or meteoroid
crashing into Mars the first time NASA
spacecraft have ever witnessed such a
collision in real time this is the
biggest new crater we've ever seen it's
about 500 feet wide or about two city
blocks across last December's Mars Quake
was the first seen to generate surface
waves along Mars crust an exciting
development for NASA scientists and for
others like this Canadian astronomer by
studying the crust this can tell us
about the early evolution of the plan
planet and the conditions so then
scientists can now take this data study
it further and try and get additional
insight into how Mars formed NASA
estimates the rock that did this damage
measured up to 12 meters across
asteroids of that size actually enter
Earth's atmosphere on the order about
once a year we see those real pretty
regularly but because Earth has a
thicker atmosphere asteroids of this
size burn up and are generally pretty
harmless the new findings come from two
missions that cost more than 1.7 billion
dollars a long-term effort that could
culminate in sending human settlers to
Mars the crater exposed ice that NASA
says could be vital for astronauts for
drinking water Agriculture and Rocket
propellant on the other hand moving to a
planet so vulnerable to meteoroids might
cause human settlers to think twice I
still don't think it would present a
huge risk to any settlements but it
would be something we'd have to think
about the mission is likely to end in a
few weeks because the Mars land Ander is
losing power after its solar panels were
mucked up by dust storms not before
making some valuable progress
Ross Lord Global News
and that is global national for this
Thursday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's
here in Canada is elbow Falls just west
of Bragg Creek Alberta beautiful spot
we'd love to see your Canada please
email it to viewers at
globalnational.com and thanks for
watching nithu garchin will be at the
anchor desk tomorrow and I'll see you
Saturday for the new reality bye-bye
foreign
[Music]